les résidents 6h et celle des
peuvent-ils installé une petite caméra
dans leur chambre pour s'assurer de ne
pas être maltraités ou se faire voler
par exemple c'est la question que devra
trancher le tribunal la cour supérieure
en l'occurrence pascal robin à l'origine
de cette cause un litige qui remonte à
quelques mois
c'est un litige qui a explosé en
novembre et décembre 2013 entre les
enfants d'une bénéficiaire et les
employés d'un ch et celle des au nord de
montréal dont on peut nommer en raison
d'une ordonnance de non-publication
les enfants ont installé dans la chambre
de leur mère une caméra de surveillance
mais une caméra qui peut qui peut
permettre de visionner les images en
direct via un téléphone intelligent ou
encore une tablette électronique ont
pour essayer aussi ce matin que cette
caméra est muni d'un détecteur de
mouvement donc à chaque fois qu'une
personne entrer dans la chambre de leur
mère ils étaient avertis les enfants par
messagerie électronique sur leur
téléphone intelligent donc la csn a
déposé un grief pour obliger la famille
a retiré cette caméra en invoquant
justement le droit des travailleurs à
travailler dans des conditions qui sont
en ligne
alors que du côté de la famille vient on
évoque plutôt des articles de la charte
québécoise des droits et libertés qui
font appel à la vie privée comme nous
dit jean pierre ménard l'avocat qui
représente la famille de la plaignante
l'argumentation repose sur deux points
de vue très différents
l'établissement à l'aigle c'est plus
qu'un dentiste de la charte québécoise
des droits ils étaient les personnes qui
reconnaît qu'à travers un doigt dès que
de son travail juste et raisonnable
nous on s'épie pitot sur ses 48 de la
charte qui dictent personnes âgées ou
handicapées à douala protection et à la
sécurité que ces familles ou les
personnes qui sont deux clubs doivent
lui apporter
c'est essentiellement le débat entre ces
deux à ces deux principes là que le juge
devra trancher
à noter que cette caméra a été retirée
jusqu'à temps que la cour supérieure
tranche est question aujourd'hui c'était
le début des plaidoiries
ça va se poursuivre mercredi matin et
par la suite selon m ménard et bien la
décision du tribunal fera sans doute
jurisprudence
oui bien sûr parce qu'à l'instant il ya
des cas non
breux au québec de caméras qui avaient
été installés merci pascal envoi